[Musique]
bonjour je suis Franck Longo maire de
fontaine en iszer une commune urbaine de
23000 habitants et je vais vous
présenter aujourd'hui un projet innovant
que nous avons lancé l'année dernière
c'est une forêt urbaine c'est-à-dire
qu'ici nous avons planté presque 500
plants d'arbres et d'arbustes pour
recréer vraiment le milieu forestier en
centrreville c'est un projet innovant
puisque c'est le premier projet
travailler avec l'Office National des
Forêts qui nous a bien sûr aidé sur les
essences des plants et des arbres et je
remercie vraiment les habitants et aussi
les entreprise puisque nous avons réussi
à nouer des partenariats et avoir des
mécèes sur ce projet pour vraiment
recréer un espace qui ne sera pas
traversable par les habitants pour
vraiment recréer ce que l'on peut
retrouver en forêt et favoriser ainsi le
développement de la biodiversité à
l'intérieur de nos communes
urbaines